The first time I felt afraid I was 41
years old. They have always told me that I was
brave when I was
little. I went to the tallest tree and
approached any animal without fear. I
like challenges. My father used to say
good work or endure all
temperatures and  when i entered
politics in colombia
i thought i could put up with all the
temperatures i wanted to put an end to
corruption in the country i wanted to cut the
links between the political class and
drug trafficking and the first time i was
elected it was because i denounced with my
own name  Corrupt and untouchable politicians
also denounced the President of the
Republic for his ties to him with the
cartels, that's where the threats began.
I had to take my very young children out
of the country
one morning hiding in the
armored car the French ambassador
took them to the road and  days later she was the
victim of an attack but escaped unharmed
the following year the colombians
were elected with the highest number of votes
she felt that people celebrated me
for the cold war and i also thought she
was brave but she wasn't I
simply had never experienced
what  It was the real fear.
This changed on February 23, 2012.
At that time, he was a candidate for the
Colombian presidency and he was
advancing the campaign agenda
when he was detained by a group of
armed men
in military uniforms, so I looked at his
rubber boots.  and i knew that the
colombia army uses leather boots
i knew that they were guerrillas from
the farc
everything happened from there very
quickly
the head of the commando gave us the order to
stop the vehicle while one of his
men stepped on a bankrupt mine  legs and for
the irish and he landed sitting
in front of me and their eyes met
then the boy mistook his
rubber boot for his leg he fell away he
started there you are in what follows and the
truth is that I felt as I feel
now  the emotions
I felt at that moment that something
broke and I became in Chile and that
his fear was not contagious and my mind
went blank and I can't think
paralyzed and when I finally reacted
to tell me nothing to kill and I didn't say goodbye
to my  sons while they entered
the depths of the jungle
the farc announced that if the government
negotiated they would kill me and I knew that the
government would not and I
went to bed every night from there to negotiate
cold sweats
the tremor the  stomach ache and
insomnia
but worse is coincidentally why from my
memory
all the telephone numbers,
addresses, names of people very
close to a significant life event were erased from my memory
and then I began to
doubt myself and my mental health and with
the doubt came despair  And with
despair came depression. I was
suffering notorious changes in
behavior and it wasn't just paranoia
in moments of panic, it was
distrust, it was hatred, and it was also
the desire to kill, and I realized that
when they had me in a chain around my neck.
to a tree
that day they kept me outdoors
under a tropical downpour
I remember that it made clear to me the
urgency of going to the bathroom what I have to
do is do it to the celtic do not close it
the garden yelled at me more and I made the
decision
At that time, the bushes went to rancherías,
winning and looking for the moment, looking for
the way to hate and tricks, who
asked her if it is to go and and I thought they are going to
make it a right. I am
not going to become a murderer. I
still have enough freedom
to decide if I want to be
There I learned that fear faced
myself, it forced me to align my
energies to align my meridians.
I learned that facing fear could
become a path of
growth. There are many emotions
when I talk about all this, but when
I think back, I was able to identify the
steps I took.  and to achieve this, and I want to
share with you
three of them, the first was to guide myself by
principles because I realized that I would
panic and have a mental block if I went
to the principles and acted correctly
I remember
the first night in a
concentration camp that the guerrillas had
built in the middle of the jungle with
bars four meters high, barbed wires
in the four corners and
armed men pointing 24 hours
a day this morning the first morning
some men arrived yelling number,
list them I know my companions
woke up scared and began to
identify themselves  with numbers in sequence
but when it was my turn
I arrived ingrid betancourt
if you want to know if I'm here call me
by name
the fury of the guards was not as much
as the fury of my companions because
of course and they were scared we were all
scared and I was afraid of them
that because of me it is not punishing but
for me above the fear was the
need to defend my identity not to
let them transform me into a thing
into a number
that was a principle was to defend what
I considered to be human dignity
the Finns are  the guerrillas had it very
well analyzed they had been
kidnapping for years and they had developed
a technique to stay to
force us to divide us
so the second step was to learn to
build trust in solidarity learn to
unite the jungle is another planet it is
a world of humid gloom with  the
buzz of missions of sayings
imagines the whistles the congas
I did not stop scratching for a single day
while over the jungle and well the
tarantulas the scorpions the anacondas
once I was face to face with an
eight meter long anaconda that  I
would have swallowed the jaguars in one bite,
but what I want to
tell you is that none of these animals
hurt us as much as the human being.
The guerrillas terrify us and spread
gossip and stimulate the relationship between
companions and envy, grudges,
distrust the first time.  That I
escaped for a long time was with a
lot of struggle, he has been in management for two years longer than
me and we made the decision to tie ourselves
with ropes to have the strength to
get into that dark room full of piranhas
and calm anise. What
we do is that during
the  During the day we hid in the mangroves
and at night we
went out we went into the water and nothing else
and she let us let the current take us
several days passed like this but she fought she
got sick
he was diabetic and in a diabetic coma
so she captured us but later
After having lived that with struggle, they now
face together, united without fear, neither
punishment nor violence, nothing could ever
divide us again. What
is true is that all those
guerrilla manipulations
did us so much damage that even today some
of those kidnapped have survived since then.
tensions inherited from all
that poisoning that the guerrillas reduced
the third step is very important to me
and it is a gift that I want to give them
the third step is learning to develop
faith I want to explain it
this way john frank pinchao was a
police non-commissioned officer who  he had been
kidnapped for more than eight years he was reputed to
be the most fearful of all of us
but he spiked violence spike and spike he
made the decision that he wanted to
escape and asked me to help him I
seem to have increased I already had like a master's degree
in an escape attempt
so we began  but we were delayed
because puncture first had to learn
to swim and all the preparations
we have to do in total
secrecy but well when
we finally had everything ready
puncture came up one afternoon and said to me
ingrid let's suppose I'm in the jungle
and two turns and turns and  he couldn't
find the way out I did he
picked up the phone and calls
up
ingrid you know that I don't believe in god they do
n't care the same as it's going to
help so that night it rained
all night and the next morning the
camp woke up and great  shock
because pincho had escaped they
made us dismantled we began to
march
during the march the guerrilla leaders
told us that pincho had died and
that they found his remains of food
for a pride by an anaconda
17 days passed and believe me I counted them
because they were torture  for me but
17 days later the news broke out on the
radio, he
was free and obviously
alive and this was the first statement
that I
know my colleagues are listening to me on the radio,
I did what you told me, I called the one in Rio and he
sent me  patrol that got me off the
top
this is an extraordinary moment because
obviously fear is contagious
but faith is contagious too and faith is not
irrational and emotional
faith is an exercise of the will
discipline of the will is what
allows us  transforming all that we are
our weaknesses our weaknesses
into strength into power it really is a
transformation it is what gives us the
strength to stand up in the face of
fear and to look above and beyond
i hope you will be reminded why
i know that  we all need to connect
with that force that in us, for the
moments when there is a storm around
our arc,
many many many many years passed
before I could return to my house
but when they put us in handcuffs in the
helicopter that finally took us out of
the jungle
everything  it happened as fast as when it was my
turn to be in a second I
saw the guerrilla commander gagged at my feet
and the rescue chief
shouting we are the army of colombia
they are free
the scream that came from all of us
when we remember our freedom continues to
rage in me
up to this moment
now i know that they can divide us all they
can manipulate us with
fear the no in the referendum for peace
in colombia or the success or the idea of ​​a
wall between mexico and the united states or
islamic terrorism
are all cases of use  politics
of fear to divide us and to
recruit them
now we all feel afraid but we
can all avoid being recruited using
those resources that we have our
principles
union faith
fear is clearly part of our
human condition and additionally it is
necessary to survive but above
all in reference to  which
we each build
this identity our personality is
true I was 41 years old the first is
that I felt afraid and feeling afraid
was not my decision but it was my decision to say
what to do with that fear
one can survive crawling with
fear but one can also  You can rise
above fear, rise up, spread your
wings and climb up
to the stars, where each
one of us wants to go.